>> Tucker: A FORM OF SOCIAL
CONTROL.
OF COURSE.
FLOYD, THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT.
WELL, THERE IS STILL
WIDESPREAD BELIEF,
PARTICULARLY ON THE RIGHT,
THAT BUSINESS INTERESTS ARE
BASICALLY CONSERVATIVE.
YOU COULD ARGUE ABOUT
WHETHER THAT WAS EVER TRUE.
CERTAINLY NOT TRUE NOW.
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
IDEOLOGICAL GAP BETWEEN
LEADERS OF AMERICA'S MOST
POWERFUL CORPORATIONS AND
SAY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
BASICALLY NONEXISTENT.
THEY AGREE ON EVERYTHING.
NOW HAVING FAILED AT THE
BALLOT BOX IN 2016, THE LEFT
IS USING OTHER MEANS TO MAKE
THE OUTCOME OF THOSE
ELECTIONS IRRELEVANT, IN
FACT.
NOWHERE IS THIS CLEARER THAN
ON THE SUBJECT OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT THERE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BEAR
ARMS IN THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
NUMBER TWO.
IN MOST STATES THERE IS NOT
A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM FOR
RESTRICTING THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
VOTERS DON'TMENT IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THE LEFT IS NOW COLLUDING
WITH LARGE COMPANIES TO ROLL
BACK YOUR RIGHTS TO BEAR
ARMS WITHOUT ANY LEGISLATION
AT ALL.
NO PUBLIC DEBATE.
THEY ARE JUST DOING IT FOR
EXAMPLE, ON THE WEBSITE RED
IT THE HATE FOR GUN DEALS
HAS BEEN BANNED.
YOU CAN'T GO THERE ANYMORE.
GOOGLE HAS BANNED THE
POSTINGS OF GUN SELLERS OR
PROMOTE THE PURPOSE OF GUNS
OR ACCESSORIES OR MAGAZINES.
BANNED VIDEO HOW TO DETACH
GUN ACCESSORIES.
ALREADY POWERFUL FIREARM
CHANNELS.
YOU CAN'T GET THE
INFORMATION ANYMORE.
BUT THE MOST AMAZING EXAMPLE
OF THIS COMES FROM CITY
BANK.
NOW, THAT COMPANY ANNOUNCED
TODAY IT WILL REQUIRE ALL OF
ITS CLIENTS TO BLOCK GUN
SALES TO THOSE UNDER 21, TO
BAR THE SALE OF BUMP STOCKS
OR HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
YOU MAY REMEMBER CITI GROUP
10 YEARS AGO THEY GOT
45 BILLION OF YOUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO GET BAILED OUT.
THAT'S WHY THEY STILL EXIST.
NOW THEY TURN AROUND AND
WORK TO UNDERMINE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF THE
TAXPAYERS WHO BAILED THEM
OUT.
WE CALLED CITIBANK TODAY TO
ASKED ASK IF THEY HE WOULD
SEND A REPRESENTATIVE OVER
TO EXPLAIN HOW THIS WORKS
BUT THEY REFUSED BECAUSE
THEY ARE COWARD.
THIS IS HAPPENING MORE AND
MORE.
MORE COMPANIES PARTICIPATING
AND TAKING ACTION ON MORE
ISSUES.
THE FEAR THE GOVERNMENT
MIGHT TAKE YOUR RIGHTS
BECOMING QUAINT.
BIG TECH AND FINANCE ARE
DOING IT ALREADY.
WITH NO PUBLIC DEBATE THEY
JUST DO IT AND TOUGH LUCK IF
YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
LIKE.
LARRY KING, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
THIS WAS ONE OF THOSE
CHANGES PEOPLE DIDN'T EXPECT
COMING.
YOUTUBE IS BANNING WHAT?
>> WELL, THEY ARE BANNING
ANY ADVERTISING OR VIDEOS
INVOLVING FIREARMS.
IT'S A LITTLE UNCLEAR, VERY
VEGAS ABOUT THE
VERYS ABOUT THE
VERYVAABOUT THE
VERYVAGUOUT THE
VERYVAGUEUT THE
VERYVAGUE A THE
VERYVAGUE ABOHE
VERYVAGUE ABOUT THE SCOPE.
VIDEOS TEACHING YOU HOW TO
LOAD AMMUNITION VERY COMMON
OR FIREARM EDUCATION TEACH
PEOPLE HOW TO USE FIREARMS.
VERY TROUBLING THAT YOUTUBE
WOULD SENSOR INFORMATION AS
A MEDIA ENTITY YOU WOULD
THINK THEY WOULD BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE SENSITIVE TO THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CENSORSHIP.
SO, VERY TROUBLING WHAT THEY
ARE ENGAGED.
IN.
>> Tucker: BUT MORE THAN
JUST A MEDIA ENTITY.
THIS IS NOT LIKE FOX NEWS,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYING
WE ARE NOT GOING TO COVER
SOMETHING.
I MEAN YOUTUBE IS THE PUBLIC
SQUARE IN EFFECT.
THEY HAVE A MASSIVE SHARE OF
ONLINE VIDEOS.
IF THEY SHUT DOWN A WHOLE
CATEGORY, THEN IT'S KIND OF
OVER, ISN'T IT?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, AS YOU SAY, THEY ARE
LIKE THE -- YOU KNOW, THE
FREE MARKET OF IDEA EXCEPT
THEY HAVE MONDAY NOPE
THEY HAVE MONOPY NOPE
THEY HAVE MONOPOLNOPE
THEY HAVE MONOPOLYOPE
THEY HAVE MONOPOLY PE
THEY HAVE MONOPOLY POWER.
PUTTING THEIR FINGER ON THE
SCALE AND DECIDING WHAT
INFORMATION THEY ARE ALLOWED
TO SEE.
THEY ARE SUPPRESSING FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT AND AT THE
SAME TIME THEY ARE
SUPPRESSING SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS BY PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM ACQUIRING INFORMATION
ABOUT A COMPLETELY LAWFUL
ACTIVITY AND FIREARMS ARE
PROTECTED BY THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IT IS DEEPLY TROUBLING AND I
THINK THAT THE PUBLIC IS
GOING TO BE VERY UPSET ABOUT
IT AND WE ARE CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE TALKING TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS TO FIND
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THESE
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES ARE DOING
AND HOW THEY ARE ABUSING
THEIR MONOPOLY POWER TO
ADVANCE A LIBERAL ANNUAL AT
THIS GUN AGENDA.
>> Tucker: REPUBLICANS THINK
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
FREQUENT.
THERE IS NOTHING FREE AT
ALL.
IT'S CONTROLLED.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> PLEASURE TO SPEND TIME
WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: FOUNDER OF
BLUEPRINT STRATEGY, HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
ANTWON, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
I'M SURE YOU AGREE WITH THE
AIMS OF CITIBANK AND YOUTUBE
AND FACEBOOK.
YOU SHARE THE SAME POLITICS
AS MOST CEOS OF THESE
COMPANIES.
DOES IT FEEL STRANGE FOR YOU
AS SOMEONE ON THE LEFT TO
FIND YOURSELF ENCOURAGING
CORPORATE POWER, SHUTTING
DOWN ORDINARY PEOPLE?
THE LEFT WAS NEVER FOR THAT
WHY ARE THEY FOR THAT NOW?
>> WELL, BEFORE I'M ON THE
LEFT, BEFORE I'M ANYTHING
POLITICAL, TUCKER, I'M A
HUMAN BEING.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO AM I.
>> I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE --
LET ME FINISH.
I KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
HAVE TO BURY SOMEONE HOW
LOVE DUE TO BEING KILLED IN
A CHURCH IN CHARLESTON AS I
EXPERIENCED ALMOST THREE
YEARS AGO.
I ALSO KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO SEE A DO NOTHING
CONGRESS AND ELECTED LEADERS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY BOTH
NATIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL NOT
ACT AFTER WE HAVE HAD
SENSELESS MASS SHOOTINGS IN
THE COUNTRY.
I APPRECIATE THE BUSINESS
LEADERS WHO HAVE STEPPED UP
TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF CONGRESS IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. DOES NOT WANT TO DO
ANYTHING.
IF GENERAL ASSEMBLIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING, LET'S LEAD BY
EXAMPLE AND BE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF HISTORY AND DO
SOMETHING THAT THE PEOPLE WE
WANT TO SERVE.
SO THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
IS.
>> Tucker: YOU AGREE WITH
THE CORPORATE MASTERS THAT
DEMOCRACY IS STUPID AND WHY
WOULD YOU LEAVE IT TO ACTUAL
VOTERS TO WEIGH IN HERE?
>> TUCKER, I AM NOT GOING TO
USE THE LANGUAGE.
>> Tucker: IT TAKES COURAGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: TO ECHO A LEAD
OPINION.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO LET ME
FINISH?
>> Tucker: I'M ASKING YOU.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY ANYMORE?
>> YOU HAVE TO LET ME -- ARE
YOU GOING TO LET ME FINISH
OR CONTINUE TO TALK LOUD AND
THINKING THAT'S LIKE THE
THING TO DO?
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
I APPRECIATE THESE PEOPLE
FOR HAVING COURAGE, STEPPING
UP TO THE PLATE AND ACTING
ON SOMETHING THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO OCCUPY THEIR BUSINESSES
WANT.
70% OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY, DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN WANT SOMETHING
DONE.
GUN REFORM.
>> Tucker: ANTJUAN YOU ARE
HAPPY THAT THE COMPANIES ARE
DOING SOMETHING THAT YOU
WANT.
WHAT IF YOU TOOK A POSITION
YOU ARE NOT IN FAVOR OF.
WHAT IF THEY SAID, PICK
SOMETHING, BLACK LIVES
MATTER BAD.
NOT GOING TO LET ANY MORE
BLACK LIVES MATTER VIDEOS ON
YOUTUBE.
WE ARE NOT CITIBANK WON'T
PROCESS ANY PAYMENT TO BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
YOU WOULD SAY WAIT A SECOND.
YOU CONTROL ALL CREDIT
CARDS.
YOU HAVE CONTROL ALL VIDEOS
AND YOU SHUT THIS DOWN.
MAYBE YOU MIGHT FEEL
DIFFERENTLY.
CAN YOU SEE WHY THERE IS
PERHAPS A FLIP SIDE TO THIS?
>> OF COURSE I CAN AND THAT
HAS HAPPENED IN MANY
INSTANCES.
>> Tucker: NO, IT HASN'T.
>> HERE IS THE BEAUTY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DISAGREE WITH PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT AGREE WITH US.
IF YOU DO NOT AGREE WITH
DICK'S SPORTING GOODS OR
WALMART OR ANY OF THESE
CORPORATIONS WHO HAVE ACTED
IN THIS MANNER OF TRYING TO
REDUCE ANOTHER INCIDENT FROM
HAPPENING.
DON'T SHOP WITH THEM.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU,
SO IF I DON'T AGREE WITH
GOOGLE WHICH HAS A COMPLETE
MONOPOLY OVER ALL HUMAN
INFORMATION.
90% MONOPOLY ON SEARCH, FOR
EXAMPLE, EVERYTHING WE KNOW
BASICALLY COMES FROM GOOGLE.
IF I DON'T AGREE WITH THEM,
I DON'T REALLY HAVE A LOT OF
PLACES TO GO.
NOTHING DUCK DUCK GO.
AS A LIBERAL, DOES THIS
LEVEL OF CORPORATE POWER,
THIS CONCENTRATION OF POWER
IN THE HANDS OF VERY SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, THAT
DOESN'T BOTHER YOU AT ALL?
>> WELL, I'M NOT A LIBERAL.
I THINK I'M APTJUAN
SEAWRIGHT.
I AGREE WITH CORPORATIONS
STEPPING UP TO THE PLATE AND
ANSWERING THE CALLS THAT
ELECTED OFFICIALS DO NOT
HAVE THE COURAGE TO DO.
>> Tucker: COULD THERE BE A
DOWNSIDE TO SETTLING
PROBLEMS.
RICHEST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
GET TOGETHER AND SAY WE ARE
GOING TO IMPOSE THIS ON A
SOCIETY.
THAT'S BETTER THAN HAVING
ELECTED OFFICIALS VOTE TO DO
SOMETHING THROUGH THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU,
TUCKER, IS THE FACT THAT
WE'RE THREE YEARS FROM
CHARLESTON, SIX MONTHS FROM
VEGAS, A MONTH OR SO FROM
PARKLAND.
AND NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE IN
THE NAME OF TRYING TO CHANGE
THE CONVERSATION.
TUCKER, YOU KNOW AS WELL AS
I KNOW, IF A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE GET TOGETHER, THAT
NUMBER WILL GROW AND
SOMETHING CAN BE DONE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: SMALL NUMBER OF
MILLIONAIRES DECIDE TO SHUT
DOWN SPEECH.